hey leute herzlich willkommen zu einem
ganz kurzen quatsch video hier deswegen
auch mal grad ganz kurz ohne face cam
weil das auch gerade eigentlich nichts
bringt bei einem quad video und zwar
packe ich eigentlich einfach eine halbe
zitrone im hintergrund beziehungsweise
zocke hier nebenbei so ein bisschen ich
bin ein crafting table gaal läuft auf
jeden fall bin ich hasse kräften tablets
dieses so packen auffällig alter junge
egal ich verstecke mich erst mal dreht
dann mit euch über das thema was ich
besprechen wollte
crafting table ne scheiße haltern
verstecke ich kenne die map auch nicht
so gut dass ich weiß hier oben ist auch
so eine große halle wo sich immer
relativ viele verstecken aber ich glaube
hier werde ich relativ schnell gekühlt
ist und bleibt einfach hier
jedenfalls wollte ich über das sprechen
was heute schon gesehen habt uns war das
mit der nuke erstmals erfolg immer noch
nicht verstanden
mein sound war schlecht weil die ja komm
genau neben mich läuft bei ihm stell
dich einfach dahin genau macht nix
stelle ich auf mich drauf geil live bei
dir junge leicht behinderten
ich hatte einen schlechten ton weil mein
mikro nicht aufgenommen wurde deswegen
hab ich in face camp sound genommen und
ich sehe immer noch kommentare drunter
warum ist die quali so schlecht haben
kommentare oder geschriebene anmerkung
und ich habe sogar noch eine anmerkung
im video reingebracht mit mir so
methoden und das gesagt mit dem
richtigen die kreise das erst mal weiß
ich verstehe nicht um die zweite sache
erst jetzt die new vision
und zwar war das ich bin deine freundin
daniela es behindert behindert behindert
ich schreibe jetzt nicht so egal
jedenfalls war das von mir nicht
beabsichtigt und ich bin einfach noch
eingelaufen dachte zwar der eingang zu
sieben und grundstück und das habe ich
auch in der aufnahme sagt weil ich wollt
sieht man ein schild in ställen einmal
wann kommt krank alle die beim videodreh
waren die wissen bescheid wo es laut
alle die beim videodreh waren wissen
bescheid und auch wollte ich ein schild
hinstellen das ist mir gleich und conny
haas hielt er und außerdem wollte ich
ihm auch ein schild hinstellen dass ich
mir von ihm genommen habe weil ich
selbst keine hatte ö
nein jedenfalls passt dann halt auch so
dass ich dann halt einen eingang gesucht
habe sonst bin ich immer oben durch
geflogen zu simon und dann bin ich halt
dann mal einfach so da reingegangen und
doch bin so hell gehe ich halt mal
einfach da unten lang vielleicht kann
man da durchgehen weil junge jetzt halt
dein maul
was willst du eigentlich super florist
um warum warum schreibt man kann ist ich
bin deine freundin ist ein schales alter
was soll das ich verstehe leute nicht
naja jedenfalls jahre alter junge ist
kiefer beiseite ich holz nicht mehr auf
den chat jeden fall und fragen ob du
aufnimmst nö ich wenn dann halte die man
reingegangen dachte halt das was der
eingang wert bin dann halt da
reingegangen wäre schlägt sich hier bin
da reingegangen und wusste halt nicht
dass wir so einen jupiter war ob ihr es
glaubt oder nicht aber wir haben
aufgenommen bevor das hochgeladen hat
und ich wusste auch nicht ob 13 yuki
oder nicht und ich bin dann halt darauf
getreten ist explodiert ich habe mich
auch in der aufnahme tausender dafür
entschuldigt hat dann allerdings danach
erfahren
leider kommt dann doch nicht ich habe
dann allerdings danach erfahren nach der
aufnahme das dehner linie gesetzt hat
und das wohl irgendwie nur als scherz
oder keine ahnung was gemacht hat oder
als falle
und ich bin reingegangen und
ich wusste in dem moment hält nicht was
mir geschieht und dachte dass ihnen der
dena trollen wollte ich habe das der
hochjagd sowie bei uns gespielt damals
der dabei den auf grundstück betreten
ist super flori ist dumm beachtet ihn
nicht sonst schenkt ihm vier nur
aufmerksamkeit leute jetzt sagt nicht
ich geschlechtern bei den abonnenten um
mich versteht solche leute nicht immer
in höhe conny ist tot
bla bla hier willst du mich heiraten ich
bin eine freundin so was alles ich meine
freundin aber das beste was meint das
finde ich eigentlich schon als
beleidigung so ein bisschen scheiße
alter beiseite mit ihm los blumentopf
laufwerk aber auch weg von mir oder
schlag hinweg oder keine ahnung wer
läuft auf jeden fall bei ihm weiß er ja
ich will sterben
lauft workbench lauf scheiße lauf
workbench online noch faxe sehr gut von
ihm eine süße alter wenn ihr ihn wo
super floris sieht beleidigt ihn einfach
wie's ausgeht nicht mehr also ich
verstehe solche leute nicht das regt
mich einfach auf jedenfalls was jetzt
sagen wollte ich hab jetzt erfahren ist
es von den er war wir haben darüber
gequatscht und wir haben auch schon
wieder dieses video aufgenommen das
video aufgenommen
modena simon und ich unsere meinung
sagen zum ganzen thema zu zeiten der
mega projekt was da zurzeit so los ist
und was alles und das wird bei mir am 29
am 30
haben wir zwei videos aufgenommen
beziehungsweise abgesetzt haben wie
gesagt das lenkrad setzen und das wird
er halt kommen da ihr vater dann auch
unsere meinung also schreibt jetzt bitte
nicht mehr unter die kommentare jahr das
megaprojekt geht ja eh nur
geht er jeden moment vorbei und so was
also schreibt so was einfach nicht
wartet einfach die videos ab
beziehungsweise bei denen und simon sind
so klein ich weiß es nicht jedenfalls
also ich verstehe es nicht warum immer
leute meint soja das geht alles den bach
runter wartet doch einfach mal ab was
wir sagen in den meinungs- video und da
dann könnt ihr darüber urteilen und hat
noch mal zu den new kids war alles
wirklich nicht meine absicht dass es bei
denen alles in die luft fliegt oder so
der wohnt jetzt übrigens auch bei mir
falls ihr das noch nicht mitbekommen
habt der ist bei mir eingezogen wo mir
meine penis kuppe rein und von daher
wartet einfach ab und schildmann
bisschen und ich wollte zeit nur dass
wir den usern das ist halt nicht meine
absicht war
das hat aus versehen war und sie meint
auch jahr macht nichts nicht schlimm
meinte denen auch und denen er zu mir
gezogen allerdings kommen die folgen
halt am 29 wo er bei mir einzig und am
dreißigsten wo wir unsere meinung sagen
morgen am 28 kommt erstmal und erfolge
wo ich mit opels aufnehme die geht 32
minuten oder so und da sind wir auf
jeden fall geht mittelmäßig positiv naja
jedenfalls wenn es euch gefallen könnt
ihr gerne ein daumen hoch gehen
beschreibt immer eure meinung zur zeit
zum megaprojekt einfach jetzt mal in die
kommentare
das ist ansonsten auslass video das
megaprojekt können jetzt eure meinung
unterschreiben und sonst möchte ich das
eigentlich erst mal nicht mehr hören von
daher ich liebe euch trotzdem alle wir
sehen uns dann im nächsten video wieder
vielleicht kommt dann noch ein
livestream ich weiß es noch nicht ich
denke jetzt kommt einer sonst mache ich
noch mal ein video heute so gegen sieben
acht oder so machen wie die ob das
stimmt oder nicht
und dann schauen wir uns das dann
einfach mal an und warten ab ciao